hello
at age 27 I was the youngest director in
Disney history at that time and I just
went into it going I'm going to go
through this door and I'm just gonna do
my best
so you guys didn't just bring with your
drawings from Aladdin we also have some
drawings from Pocahontas
here's the gold what did Father say
brother this is AI this is AI amongst
many other things
I feel like you've broken like reality
or logic or something my head is kind of
Twisted and changed in a way now my
heart is beating I don't know if you
could pick that up on this one this is a
groundbreaking moment I can't believe
we're here for it I feel like I'm gonna
throw up
thanks to sports
answering this video
what's up everybody I'm Jordan and
welcome to another episode of animators
react with the Bancroft twins but before
we get into it I'm here to talk to you
about our long time sponsor Squarespace
if you don't know anything about web
design well me neither but you don't
need to because Squarespace makes it
super easy with their award-willing
templates they literally have something
for everyone one of my favorite newer
features of Squarespace is their video
Studio you can literally Edit Pro level
videos in Squarespace the Squarespace
video studio app helps you make and
share engaging videos to tell your story
grow your audience and drive sales one
of the best features that Squarespace
offers is the analytic tools learn where
your site visits and sales are coming
from and analyze which channels are most
effective a lot of great stuff to help
grow your business listen I see you guys
out there all you creatives I know
you're trying to launch an online
business right now so stop making
excuses Squarespace is here to help you
go to squarespace.com Corridor crew so
you can get 10 off of your first website
or domain all right I gotta clear out
because we got some animator Legends
coming in
foreign welcome back to another episode
of animators react Tom Bancroft is
joining us and he's brought his brother
Tony Bancroft so Tony why don't you kick
things off tell us a little bit about
yourself what do you worked on I've
worked in animation like my whole career
33 years or something mostly at Disney I
animated Pumba the warthog and The Lion
King on beating the Beast it was
cogsworth o'clock Yago in Aladdin oh
yeah and I co-directed Disney's Mulan
man what a resume and Tom you know last
time you joined us you gave us a little
insight into all the incredible stuff
you've worked on as well but just for a
little refresher for everybody so a lot
of the same movies Tony actually worked
at the same time at Disney I was in the
Florida Studio Disney Florida Studio
Tony was in the California studio right
actually brought some original drawings
from Pocahontas can't wait I got some
from Aladdin of Iago the parrot there's
nothing more special than when people
who have worked in these things bring in
like this piece of history with well
let's jump in and take a look at some of
this work and hear some cool insights
come warm Yourself by the fire thank you
nope nope nope oh this is crazy this is
literally my first animated scene at
Disney they didn't have a lot to give
out and I was like a junior animator and
stuff so I literally got the doors
opening up as the Beast came in oh hello
that's it
oh yeah I worked like a week on these
doors so I like put love and care into
those lines you know
I got like a week's wage off of Disney
off of that yeah you see how they kind
of vibrate a little bit too I wanted a
little like you know cartoony shake to
them when you're coming into Disney for
like the very first time you're like
you're gonna work on a movie what kind
of stuff do they usually give you is it
things like that like I need to do that
and we get what's called booger
animation and I have a couple of those
in here and booger animation is
basically just like these long wide
shots of the characters and they're
really small so you know literally it is
small little booger sized drawings I I
also did booger animation on Beauty and
the Beast but mine was a lot of those
guys carrying the log and like let's go
kill them kill the Beast almost all the
incidental characters if it wasn't
Gaston I probably did it in the whole
let's go kill the Beast basically
anybody with a pitchfork or torch in the
background yeah yeah most of it
it is weird being as old as we are
looking back at stuff that we did in our
20s probably yeah yeah at the very
latest but unlike Tony I'm I'm doing
those like crowds of them in in a week
instead of just
I was in the Burbank Studio like the
kind of the A-list the time was like in
Florida he was like the b list it's like
Disney Sweatshop in the 90s yeah
foreign
so we're going to take a jump over to
Aladdin now we both worked on a lad and
actually we both did Yago but Tony did
more yeah yeah we're both credit for
that Tom did some other characters too a
little bit of Jafar and stuff but I did
this whole sequence here with Iago
acting like a parrot and then the sultan
loves to feed him crackers he doesn't
want them
shoves it in his mouth it's very
cartoony too my supervising animator
Iago Wilson was like just shove his fist
all the way through the back of his
throat and I was like can we do that it
seems really cartooning for this movie
but he's like yeah just shove it in
there and so I brought the drawings from
this scene too because I thought it was
just a lot of fun wow so there's him and
his body drops off but he's doing a
little head shake right before school
The Sultans The Sultans tiny little
hands back and then he goes forward into
a kind of a take there
funny drawing with a blink and then he
gets pulled out the shoulder Rises up
and he gets pulled out of frame so when
you're animating Iago do you try to work
in Gilbert godfreed into Iago or do you
just take the voice Lines by themselves
and forget about everything else yeah I
get this question a lot but absolutely
you're influenced by the voice I mean
how can you not be influenced by Gilbert
Godfrey he's got that he's always very
uh the Clint I can't take it anymore
that tonality you want to get that in
the face you know that causes the
squintiness of the eyes yeah it Squints
a lot right and you see that in Yago it
comes through oh my God on the last
episode when you joined us you mentioned
that there's a lot of yourself in Mushu
the dragon which you designed so when
you're drawing Iago is there you and
Iago yeah yeah believe it or not yeah
when there's different mannerisms and
stuff like that we're kind of acting it
out you know I'm playing it out a little
bit in my mind but also sometimes in
front of a mirror and a lot of those
mannerisms are in Yago when he's like
dancing in the in the song with the
genie and stuff I've made up that little
dance and stuff that he's doing there we
can't help but put ourselves into our
world and it really starts with the
supervising animator and in this case it
was Will Finn he really did that deep
dive when he was designing the character
to really make it feel like he's like a
little character if Gilbert's not a
really tall guy either so there's a lot
of just even in his structure it feels
like Gilbert when Tony first show showed
me this as a twin brother and an
animator I was surprised this was a big
jump for Tony really coming into his own
as an animator and I do remember that
that's what I finally remember is like
oh my gosh he's he's bringing the next
level
it's right here
foreign
so you guys didn't just bring with your
drawings from Aladdin we also have some
drawings from Pocahontas
here's the gold and this is a big stack
because it's a pretty big scene so the
stack obviously has to do with how long
the scene is but this is where she's
first kind of just poked out she's like
looking around and then Mikko comes up
you don't see Mikko you can see like a
little red uh drawing in there that's
where Miko is gonna be so I went first
and then another animators went second
and did Mikko and by the way flit comes
up in this one too and then I had to
have her kind of crawl wow that's a lot
of foreshortening and perspectives so
they shot live action for Pocahontas
almost the whole movie was shot in live
actually first they say that we made
Pocahontas twice much like they did in
Cinderella and all those older films and
it's because we wanted it to move very
realistically and so we had that
reference to go by but in the case of
this shot they decided later on that she
would climb out of the scene so the
actual animation of her climbing out I
just had to make up oh really that's my
favorite I assume that you had live
action references
[Music]
when looking at Pocahontas here like
it's a very like minimalist character
when it comes to the face like literally
eyes zero wrinkles two very subtle
nostrils basically the lips are almost
just like a color patch so we have such
a very simple clean character how do you
make sure that your proportions are
always the same in that you know the
eyes aren't a little too big or a little
too small or too far apart or too close
together well we try but we don't always
nail it uh you know the cleanup
department at Disney was super important
and and I want to give them a lot of
credit because on a film like Pocahontas
especially there was about 20 different
animators on Pocahontas Glen King was
the supervising animator and he knew how
to draw her all the rest of us were just
trying to draw like Glenn and he would
do draw overs over our drawings and
there's a lot in that scene I just
showed where he had gone over and
improved it and made it look more like
her and then I would go from there and
so that guidance is a big part of what
you're asking and of course the model
sheets that's why we make model sheets
it's so we can look at them constantly
as we're drawing and go okay that's the
distance between her eyes and we can
kind of you get good at seeing the
positive and the negative shapes of how
the characters should work and be drawn
from different angles but then it's
still by the time it gets to the cleanup
department they have to have another
whole pass at it to go okay this is how
Tom Bancroft draws Pocahontas as opposed
to Glen King to opposed to pres romelios
there were so many different animators
we all had our own little version of how
we drew her and so they would help to
kind of control that make it look like
one person drew that character looking
back at these Disney films it's like a
yearbook all these shots were done by
people we knew and cared about and we
see it in them you know we see them
inside of those scenes so hey here we
are talking about classic Disney
animated films in the 90s what are some
classic non-disney animated films from
the 90s that you might want to see us
look at in the show please leave a
comment down below
okay so this sequence this is a good
sequence because it's one of the only
times that we work 3 000 miles apart I
was in Florida he was in the California
Studio yet we were working on the exact
same sequence at the same time
geez it's a lion
run pooper move it hey yeah I did Pumbaa
in this one Mike Surrey who's a good
buddy of mine we shared an office
together he did Timon and then Tom came
into town from Florida to do young Simba
he was assigned a young Simba on the
film repeat after me
Hakuna Matata Hakuna Matata what a
wonderful phrase I did that one there
where he says Hakuna Matata and I did
this like Jimmy Durante kind of thing
with his nose there like when it comes
towards camera and goes
Hakuna Matata yeah it's how do you get
human Expressions onto an animal's face
that's like the bread and butter of
Disney right we're doing that with the
objects and Beauty and the Beast with
animals we do the same things it really
is just a matter of trying to dig deep
into the anatomy the understanding of
the actual animal and then
caricaturizing them giving these human
attributes I mean this is the heart of
acting like back in the day they used to
call us actors with a pencil you know a
lot of people talk about oh the drawing
and how hard and all that you know
really the hardest part for us as
animators was the part we didn't never
talk about which was the acting the
performance part and then the drawing
part of it hopefully is secondary and
that's the hard part to get to the point
of drawing ability and things like that
and getting to know the character and
how to draw the character where all that
part of it becomes in the back of your
head and what's in the foreground of
your head is just the performance and
the acting
I heard you mentioned something called
anim tune anim tune is the world's best
student films what we've done is we're
going all around the world and finding
student films at all the best animation
schools some of them are amazing and
they put a Year's worth of work into
this we share the monetization with them
we advertise it so we get as many eyes
as possible on the student films that's
super cool all the time people are
talking about you know how much they
love traditional animation how much they
love like classic kind of style cartoons
and animation if you like it it still
exists yeah go check out anim tune of
course go check out pencilish Studios I
don't know if you have a YouTube channel
or an Instagram or anything like that
Instagram I'm Puma guy
Puba has two A's two ways
[Music]
I want to ask you about directing when
you were starting Mulan what was your
emotional state like looking at this
mountain I was horrified I am telling
you the truth I was so scared to death
about this because I was given at age 27
I was the youngest director in Disney
history at that time and I was just
terrified because I there was more that
I didn't know about directing than I did
for sure and I just went into it going
I'm going to go through this door and
I'm just gonna do my best when directing
an animated film what does that entail
what what is it when you're a director
well there's less of this you know
remember you see like a lot of photos of
live action directors it's always like
you're talking to the and they're like
you go over here and you're gonna come
here yeah it's none of that you know I
was Tom's director on Mulan and Tom's
doing Mushu and we'd issue him a scene
that meant we'd have a meeting and we'd
just talked through the scene about what
the outcomes are of the scene what are
the important elements that have to get
by like when he comes up and he goes I
live
early
that was a great example of where Tom
surpassed as an actor what we were
expecting in that moment but as a
director working with an actor like Tom
in this case you know we love that he's
coming up with performance ideas that
fits right into what that moment is and
then sometimes we're catching things
that need to be fixed or refined because
we're looking at you know the overall
the big picture where an animator in
this case is only thinking scene to
scene Tom's head is all in the moment
and we're thinking more big picture of
maybe an overall Arc well we're going to
save that because mushu's going to do
that later those kind of things are
really key to bring up in a director's
meeting
Disney tradition over the years A lot of
times directors will put themselves in
their movies oh wait you're in the movie
myself and my co-director citizens
I'm the big one
we love this sequence because we
literally like jump to our desks and
that's kind of represented like the end
of the film we finished it and then we
die
oh man hey Tom you have a YouTube
channel what's the thing that you want
people to do most after they watch your
videos subscribe you got it consider
subscribing if you like watching our
shows here on corridor
so we made an animation what in the time
since uh you came and visited us we've
developed a technique to let us
basically Trace over footage of
ourselves on the green screen to make it
look like a cartoon no way it's going to
look a little different at first but I'm
curious at what does it fade and just
become a thing that you watch it's like
nicomation yeah that's how we're doing
it all right
it's better in the backgrounds than in
beating the Beast I know look at that
shot isn't it crazy because we're
figuring this whole thing out it's just
Tom Cruise there how did Tom Cruise get
into this yeah
let us not forget the power to settle
this ladies in the palm of our hands
look at the lighting too that's crazy
this is AI this is AI amongst many other
things yeah I know look how good that
looks we're out of a job everybody
everybody's out of a job this is killing
me a little bit all right some lip syncs
off yeah there's some bad mouth shapes
but
[Laughter]
do it
ah
the Shadows look like they're underwater
a little bit they're like ripply effects
I don't even care that it's moving all
around those Shadows I don't care
awesome look at that shot like these
shots are amazing for the entire Kingdom
and The Crown let's finish this whatever
you did here you both in Pandora's Box
somebody had to open it figured it'd be
us this is gonna blow up the internet I
should hope so it comes out in three
days are we the first to see this is so
excited right now that was a feature
film oh my gosh you guys oh my God that
was crazy good I I mean it I know we're
supposed to be reacting that was real I
can't believe that I've never been so
happy and so extremely upset at you like
literally it was like when I watched Toy
Story for the first time okay Judy's
dead I feel like you've broken like
reality or logic or something my head is
kind of Twisted and changed in a way now
since I've seen this when we're putting
everything out there with we did this we
have a full like click-by-click tutorial
on our website but like on our YouTube
channel we just we kind of go into the
process basically what we do is you know
obviously all things written we actually
just like a cartoony voice acted all
first and we have a whole storyboard
that we do so it's all very like classic
process there oh okay and then rather
than drawing these scenes by hand you've
actually animate it on the green screen
it's almost like motion capture after
you get everything filmed then we have
to run it through the AI process which
basically traces the video the style for
this one is actually pulled from an old
anime Vampire Hunter D bloodlust but in
the process we learned that like if you
wanted to create your own style and
generate it you only have to draw about
50 to 60 pictures of your character
that's like my doors opening seriously
in the bees or theoretically you can
have an artist draw almost like the
keyframes so to speak and like draw the
style guides and all that so you can use
a real life motion capture with all the
Styles and characters that you build and
you kind of bring them together we'd
realize that once we filmed ourselves in
the green screen we traced it we put on
the background it actually just looked
like video it was kind of boring oh it
wasn't until he sat down like okay I
want him to whip this way and we're
gonna do this the background we're going
to add these effects like and you
actually break it down and start adding
animation that all right kids you just
heard that they spent real money
no you can't just turn around do this
tomorrow okay obviously the biggest
hurdles is the animation part of this
the lighting of it and all that I'm sure
is some of the tricky stuff where the
background's the easiest part because
you could just sort of describe it and
it already knew the style and it would
create those shots so the backgrounds
are actually 3D what yeah Sam went on to
the epic game store and bought a
cathedral level that someone had made
and it already looked beautiful it had
all the props it was it's just a
gorgeous 3D model could be fired up
Unreal Engine and then what he would do
is he go through ahead and be like okay
the first shot's a shot of you know Nico
coming through the door so I need a shot
looking that direction he'd put the
camera there grab a screen grab and you
know it looked like a video game render
and then we'd take that in similar to
how we're filtering the video of
ourselves we would filter that one frame
to the AI just to give it a little bit
of the painter look okay we're just
doing a very small style transfer to it
that's it I love how you rolled this out
too like hey guys you want to see my new
ride
again it's like a VW bug or something
and then he's like a Tesla get a little
animation why don't we watch it 20
minutes later
I don't know you guys might want to see
it what do you think you could have
easily have done one minute of this and
we would have been impressed but you
went full on let's go you're gonna keep
talking monologue monologue was that all
just built in or you just have a funny
gag no because I was doing experiments
starting in October like trying to
figure out that this process would even
be a thing and once it was kind of
working it was one of those things where
it's like if we're gonna do this and
we're gonna go out and show people like
hey you can use AI for art and like try
to make some cool out of it because it's
kind of a controversial thing and a lot
of people talk about how it's low effort
killing jobs it's like if we're gonna
make something it can't just be a test
it has to be a real product with a real
story it's like you watch it from
beginning to end and it's a full film
and so he just committed to it you know
Tom and I probably do represent a lot of
um yeah
anti-ai folks so you picked two people
that were obviously way over on the
other side of this and not only am I
really scared to say this but I'm really
convinced that there's some good stuff
here that can be utilized to make some
great great animations my heart is
beating I don't know if you could pick
that up on this bike
it's crazy this is a groundbreaking
moment I can't believe we're here for it
when it comes to AI there's a lot of
different types of tools and you can use
AI tools to denoise footage or you know
like clean up some rotoscoping or change
somebody's voice to be more Gruff if
your truck ain't dripping wet with mud
and scum well then it ain't a truck you
piece of there's so many Tools in
that world I don't want to see people
just ripping off other people right what
I do want to see is it becoming easier
for people to make things you know I
hope when people look at this they don't
see us as like oh we're killing things
necessarily but like more so like we're
enabling and let's be honest you guys
are artists right so you definitely had
to be an artist to make this right you
can't just say AI make this it can make
it look pretty it can't make it go to
the next level that you guys went to
yeah there's so many abstract visual
elements in animation especially like
anime where it's like you know sometimes
the background goes away sometimes
there's speed lines sometimes it's not
speed lines you know these are all
decisions that are very abstract
decisions that like a human has to make
and decide that's the key I think it
really comes down to Artistic choices
that should be made by artists and I
think that's the thing that at first is
like what the computer did all this but
it's not it's you guys are artists you
guys are making all these choices
iterations and iterations of choices to
come to this so it's valid I get that
a little tear coming down I know I feel
like I'm gonna throw up
Well Done You Killed animation all right
Toy Story
it's over I really appreciate you guys
coming in because even though we're
trying all this crazy new stuff like you
guys are the ones that have actually
done the work and like made the pieces
that culture remembers and it's an honor
to have you guys here and to just be
able to show you my stuff and see you
guys a little bit excited about it
really means a lot but also holding
these actual drawings which I consider
like little bits of History it's really
special so thanks for joining us thanks
man yeah it all comes back to high-res
please
yeah when you become Steve Jobs or Walt
Disney
all right guys see you on the next one
thanks for watching